what is your purpose so I got a great
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys ruff foul who wrote in to
say Evan tell me what is your major
dream all like purpose i have a problem
because i choose a path and i'm walking
this path and after one week two weeks i
wonder if it's my way my pack my real
dream and after that wondering i have a
really bad mood for a few days if life
has sense without your mission it's
really hard because i'm still drifting
and i don't know where to swim I'm 28
please help sorry for my English rough
out this is a great question a really
important one and I really feel for you
without i remember when i sold my first
software company i was in a similar
situation where I didn't know what I
wanted to do next I felt like I put all
this energy into this company and now it
was gone and I didn't know what I wanted
to do with my life and I kept a journal
and I started keeping track of the
things that I enjoyed in my life and I
and I hope that somehow those things
would connect somewhere for me to find
my purpose and do something even bigger
and greater the thing I discovered is
you can't force out your purpose and and
this sounds like what you're doing right
you're trying to force it you're trying
to do something like okay this is what
I'm going to do and then you put so much
pressure on it to work out and then a
dozen than a week or two goes by the guy
that's not what I want to do and then
you're depressed and you launch on this
something I so this is my purpose and
you start that and you put so much
pressure on it being the thing and then
that doesn't work out and you fall back
and you say the depression what you need
to understand is that if you don't know
what your purpose is yet you have to go
on a journey of discovery this is
something everybody has to go through
it's funny because most people most
people they live their lives like this
right average boring they don't have
they don't know what their purpose is
they don't even think about what their
purpose is they just they go to work
they wake up you know they probably hit
their job delivering for the evenings
and weekend
and they love their family that's most
people in their life right they don't
strive for anything major they don't
have major dreams for themselves but if
they do they don't feel like it's
possible so just live in this flat line
then when people discover that hey I
want to live a purposeful life I want to
do something important I want my life to
have meaning I want it to mean something
when I die that I lived here I had an
impact on this world whether it's from
you know meeting a friend with from
watching the video reading a book
something sparks that changing unit says
I want my life to have meaning but you
don't know what that meaning is yet and
so you realize this you live in this
normal life and then you sink now you're
now you're depressed because you don't
like your life you want you like to have
meaning you see these people living
meaningful lives and then you realize
I'm not there yet and this is a really
important part when you've gone through
that dip this is really crucial because
you can either stay there just churning
churning churning churning going through
idea after idea after i did nothing
working out or you can climb through
that and end up way up here we are
living your purpose we are having an
impact where you have a meaningful life
it's so counterintuitive and it's so
tough because when you want something
badly you tend to focus everything on
that and you can't force love it's like
you're meeting a girl for the first time
and you want her to marry you that's not
how it works the same thing applies to
finding your life's purpose what you're
meant to do here you need to try a bunch
of different things if you have no idea
what it is you need to just try a whole
bunch of different things and not put so
much pressure on yourself for this thing
to be the one when i sold my software
company i did a bunch of different
things I hooked up with a venture
capital company I was helping raise
funds for entrepreneurs I was helping
some friends of mine who had businesses
I thought about starting my own company
up again I but honest I didn't know what
I wanted to do but I said yes to a lot
of opportunities just to see where it
went and if I would go I would try it if
i liked it i would keep going if I
didn't then I would stop the big change
for me came when the ymca asked me to
come and deliver a presentation to help
their entrepreneurs they had a group of
entrepreneurs who were graduating their
program and they wanted me to come and
speak to them and share my story and for
me at that time it was just another just
another thing to do sure why not come
I'll try that why not help help
entrepreneurs sure let's do it and even
though only three people show up to that
event and by you know every rational
reasonable marking it was a total
failure I felt something inside me that
said I need to keep going I need to find
ways to do this I had no idea if I'd
ever make money doing this I had no idea
why I love doing this but I knew that I
had to find the way to keep going
because of all the things that I had
tried this one spoke to me and I had to
find a way to keep going and I've built
that up so you need to find your ymc
moment and it's going to come from
explain so say yes to things try things
help people out try a new skill try
different things until you fall in love
with something and when you fall in love
then keep going and that will take you
on your journey to find in your purpose
and live in a meaningful life because if
you put all that pressure on yourself
it's not going to work out and you just
going to toil down in here run an idea
after idea of the idea I'm never
breaking through I badly want this for
you because it's so painful living down
there when you realize you don't have a
purposeful life but it's totally worth
it when you figure it out it's totally
worth it believe those you watch like
the video thumbs up below leave a
comment let me know how you found your
purpose how you found meaning in your
life I'd love to hear from you leave it
in the comments section below and click
on my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon
I